And the number of these phrases
and colocations and phrasal verbs
they're they're almost unlimited.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann and today I wanna
talk about collocations and phrasal verbs.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So we often hear that the language,
when we're trying to learn a language,
consists of not just individual words,
but you know, chunks of, of words like
phrases, uh, that there are certain
words that are typically always used
with other words and these are called
collocations, like put to this...
in the same location, you know,
that they combine with each other.
Certainly, uh, there's a whole,
you know, industry, books and other
publications on the subject of phrasal
verbs, uh, in English, you know, we get
sick, get on the bus, get with it, get
going, all kind, uh, you know, take a
hike, you know, there's all kinds of
phrases that go with certain verbs and
these are now called phrasal verbs.
So we have these terms:
collocations, phrasal verbs.
This is not unique to English.
Uh, although reading some of these
textbooks, you would think that it's
something unique to English that
you have, uh, expressions phrases,
where certain words will naturally
be combined with other words.
Uh, but this happens elsewhere.
I'm certainly seeing it in Persian.
Uh, and I think it happens
in, in all languages.
There's this thing about words,
it's, it's not only which words,
words like to be friends with, you
know, colocate with, hang around
with, uh, there's also an issue of
order, like in terms of adjectives.
It's amazing.
If, if I'm gonna say there is
a new red expensive car, I'm
gonna say it in that order.
And I can almost anticipate,
like, I'll just say it.
It's not an expensive new red car.
It might be, but typically
there's a certain order.
Uh, and, and, and so the native speaker
is gonna get it right most of the
time, but it's, it's not important.
You can jumble the order.
It's not so important.
What is though interesting in all of
that is that these are habits in the
language, habits that we acquire.
And so, you know, whenever I have tried
to learn set phrases, and they exist
in every language, even in even sort
of express sayings like raining cats
and dogs or the equivalent in other
languages, uh, I can never remember them
because they don't come up that often.
But for the native speaker, because the
native speaker has humongous quantity of
exposure to the language words they have
heard and read that they'll have come
across cats and dogs, raining cats and
dogs often enough that they will naturally
use it when it's appropriate to use it.
The person who buys a book full
of English expressions, even
if they can remember them, they
probably won't use them correctly.
And so collocations, it's fine
to have that as a term, but
there are certain expressions...
and I was just thinking about
this, for example, in English we
say, as far as I know, far, as
far as I know, doesn't make sense.
Why?
As near as I know, as far as I know,
uh, you know, that expression could
have been as near as I know, because
we can say as near as I can tell,
as far as I can tell, as far as I
know, these are just expressions that
we kind of get used to, to using.
And it's interesting, the equivalence in
other languages use a different imagery.
Uh, you know, in Japanese ... like within
the limits of what I know ... or, um,
uh, again with the sub subjective or,
um, somewhat similar in Russian ... uh,
what else have we got, uh, ... you
know, in Chinese, again, it's different.
The problem is that if any speakers
of those languages try to translate
from those expressions into English,
the resulting expression will
sound funny: as much as I know.
No, no we say as far as I know,
we don't say as much as I know,
or as many as I know from Russian.
As I know from Chinese or within
the limits that I know from
Japanese, we just don't say that.
How do you get...
and, and the number of these phrases
and collocations and phrasal verbs,
they're, they're almost unlimited
so that, you know, first of all, the
idea that you could buy a dictionary
of these and somehow learn them and
sprinkle your language with these i,
I think is a little bit unrealistic.
If you already know them, if you have
already come across them in different, um,
contexts and you then find a book which is
full of these, and especially if it's, you
know, in the same language, so that you're
kind of exposing yourself to the language
and reading up on useful expressions
and staying in the language when you
are already at a fairly advanced level.
You know, I can see that as
a, as being a useful exercise.
However, I think the, the only way,
and this is a familiar theme with
me, the only way that you can become
confident in using these is if you have
had enough exposure to the language.
This, by the way, also applies to slang.
It applies to swear words, which to
my mind are taboo, uh, until you are
comfortable enough in the language that
you can use them naturally and correctly.
It, it applies to, for example, in
Chinese, they have ...which are these
sort of very literate sounding, uh,
four character expressions that usually
have a reference to something in
Chinese history or Chinese literature.
And if you use them, you sound very
erudite, but I've never been able
to remember enough of them so that I
could sprinkle them through my Chinese
conversation and, and sound like, uh, you
know, and impress the Chinese speaker.
Um, so I, I think this whole idea
that you can sort of zero in on
phrasal verbs, collocations and
thereby enrich your language...
I think this might be possible when
you are already fairly advanced
in the language and you're doing
it out of interest and for fun and
with a realization that you won't
remember much, you won't remember
many of these expressions, but
it's fun, kind of reviewing them.
But at an earlier stage in the
language, if you think you can sort
uh, leverage yourself up, ladder
yourself up by focusing in on
phrasal verbs and, um, collocations.
I think you may be disappointed
and I think that you're still
better off to continue to massively
expose yourself to the language.
And you'd be surprised at how often
these expressions that are almost
limitless show up in all the things
that you're reading and listening to.
And so you'll, your brain will naturally
get used to the fact that certain words
are used with certain other words.
So that's my take on
collocations and phrasal verbs.
Uh, I hope you found that useful.
Thank you.
Bye for now.